[Musique]
si maurice genevoix entre au panthéon
c'est en raison de ce livre ceux de 14
pas un roman mais un journal de guerre
écrit à chaud à partir de notes prises
dans les tranchées et mises en forme
dont les années suivantes
j'ai constaté ce besoin de témoigner
chez les plus frustes et tout le monde
n'y avait pas un soldat qui naît dans
son sac un carnet sur lequel il notait
ses impressions parce qu'il avait le
sentiment de vivre des événements hors
série exceptionnel monstrueux et tout de
suite ça éveiller chez eux le désir de
les perpétuer les de laisser un
témoignage dont ceux de 14
maurice genevoix ne cache rien de
l'horreur qu'il découvre dès son arrivée
sur le front en août 1914
à 23 ans ce qui lui vaudra la censure de
nombreuses pages à sa première parution
toute sa vie le besoin de témoigner la
compagnie
quand encore la voix du mot colonel qui
s'appelait bourgenay me disant je ne
vois c'est un fruit un moment j'ai senti
soumet pas quelque chose bouger je me
suis penché et j'ai le sentiment qu'il y
avait un homme là dessous j'ai écarté la
boue j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu j'ai vu
changer en effet un miraculé a
ressuscité dont les premiers montrent
été je ne suis pas mort et y en a eu
d'autres
alors c'est vous dire à quel point
d'espoir les éléments même la colline la
terre le ciel la spa puis était inhumain
certains s'en sortent mais la mort est
partout en ces heures sous verdun ou
ceux qui ne se noie pas dans la boue
sont rattrapés par les balles c'est là
pour la première fois que j'ai entendu
le bruit d'une balle qui entrent dans un
corps humain
un voisin boom à chaque match jours et
alors aussitôt après on voit le type par
terre et s'il est blessé à mort une rade
de roide et l'immobilité et ça n'est
plus qu'un khaddam et c'est là pour la
première fois que j'ai vu vraiment tombé
à mes côtés des hommes vivants et qu'une
balle ans anna fragments de seconde dont
une balle faisait un tué voilà alors
c'est là que j'ai fait le point
l'apprentissage de la guerre
parmi ces hommes qui meurent à quelques
mètres de lui et dont il entend le
dernier râle deux écrivains l'auteur de
la guerre des boutons louis pergaud et
celui du grand moun alain fournier et le
talent de jeunes voix lui aurait pu ne
jamais être révélée car en avril 1915 il
voit à son tour la mort de près j'étais
blessé par un type qui m'attirait une
première balle qui m'a coupé leurs
terres humérale et qui m'a sidéré j'ai
créé mon bras arraché et je suis tombé
sur place et malheureusement pour moi
dans une trouée sous bois ils me
voyaient encore est bien le même tir air
à manoeuvrer sa culasse matière une
deuxième balle kim a également atteint
au bras gauche qui a fait tressauter mon
bras que je cherchais des yeux j'avais
l'impression qu'ils avaient été arrachés
et en le voyant tressauter flotte de la
deuxième balle je me suis dit il est
encore là et à ce moment là ils avaient
manoeuvré sa culasse une troisième fois
dans l'intervalle il m'a tiré une autre
balle qui m'a atteint à la poitrine mais
comme le geste que j'avais fait pour
regarder chercher mon bras des yeux
avait fait refuser le buste alors cette
balle m'a simplement coupé simplement
une façon de dire coupez le pectoral a
filé entre deux côtes m'a déchiré la
presse tap lèvres est sorti sous le bras
en me déchire encore le bras si bien que
le bras a pris les trois balles sa
guerre s'arrête au bout de huit mois le
laissant définitivement handicapé de la
main gauche
mais de sa main droite il écrira ses
cinq récits de guerre rassemblés en 1949
sous le titre ce de 14 dans une version
où rien n'est censuré y compris le
moment où cette même ma droite arme et
tire dans le dos de trois allemands pour
les abattre mais c'était eux oui